welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul AKA your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
we're breaking down a big reveal at the
end of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
throughout this video we're going to be
going over the major thing everyone
missed about one of the ending scenes
which is now being cleared up by James
Gunn and one of the VFX artists the
movie has a lot of things going on with
it but this confirms the fate of one of
the characters who there was a bit of a
question mark over it's difficult to
title stuff like this and do thumbnails
that don't ruin things but I'm still
gonna drop a spoiler warning in case you
haven't managed to see it with gun
talking about it openly on Twitter
though I think it might be fair game but
yeah back out now if you've still not
seen the movie without the way huge
thank you for clicking this and let's
get into Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3.
so first up huge shout outs to
thedirect.com who Unearthed this they do
a lot of great reporting on Marvel stuff
and you should definitely check them out
on Twitter if you're into the MCU now to
give some context the movie ends with a
high evolutionary being beat by The
Guardian cheering the big Face-Off that
led to a Face-Off
a rocket had the high evolutionary at
his Mercy but rather than killing him he
decided to let him live the high
evolutionary wasn't able to see the
perfection in imperfection and the
ending revealed him to be extremely
pathetic the guy was such an evil
character and watching the movie for a
second time I still can't understand why
he had such a deep rooted hate for
everything however we could potentially
learn more things about him in the
future but I'll talk about that more as
we get further into the video the film
was very much about everyone getting a
second chance and even though rocket
didn't kill him in the end his fate was
left with a big question mark over it we
never saw his body or a scene of him
dying on the ship and therefore people
have been kind of wondering exactly what
happened to him now that ship ended up
blowing up and though it seemed like he
would have perished during this the
character was actually saved during that
Stampede scene the directs say that
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 VFX artist
Miguel Montserrat recently confirmed
that the high evolutionary was actually
hidden in the movie at one point as
everyone exits the ship monsterat was
the artist that worked on the Stampede
scene and he revealed that Rax could be
seen carrying the high evolutionary out
of there as everyone exited the ship
it's difficult to make out but upon
zooming into edrax is we can see him
running out with the evolutionary held
up on his shoulders now before we get
into the next part of the video
discussing more I want to give a huge
shout out to our sponsors
comicbookdirect.com the site is the
perfect place for physical collectors
and they sell a range of Manga comics
and also figures they work with all the
big Publishers like Marvel and DC and
what makes them different is that you
can click on a specific Runner issue and
instantly subscribe to it that means
you're never going to miss an issue as
they send out every single one to you
they're also doing a big sale right now
and you can get 20 off your first order
by clicking the link below huge thank
you again to comicbookdirect.com and
definitely head over there right after
this anyway the article Was Then
followed up by James Gunn responding to
it on Twitter everything was barked off
with them sharing some concept off of
the animals like floor Lila and also
thiefs Twitter user Angel Gonzalez then
posted the article and then gun followed
this up by saying for people who want
this spoiler what's pointed out in the
article is very much in the movie sounds
like me saying very much all the time
anyway this out now confirms it I think
and it shows that the high evolutionary
is still alive and out there somewhere
check whether you even spoke to phase
zero recently and stated that you didn't
see the character go down with the ship
and that there could be some more things
coming he also said well let me just put
it this way I'm hoping you'll see an
extended version or maybe an alternate
ending you know that we certainly did
film the point is that rocket doesn't
shoot me they make a point of saying why
don't you kill him and he says no I'm
not gonna kill him and then you don't
actually see me go down with the ship so
I'll just leave it at that so yeah the
guy's still alive Drax you son of a
you saved his life now what does
this mean for the future well there's
lots of possibilities and lots of
different in ways that they can take
things with the character I know that a
big few time at the moment is to say
that he's someone who can replace Kang
and that he might even end up being a
Kang variant I think people are kind of
going all over the place with stuff like
that and yeah just because he's black
mate it doesn't mean he's a Kang Varian
you see what I'm saying now there is a
lot of things going on with Jonathan
Mages at the moment obviously but I
personally think that they'll keep these
two characters separate because there's
no reason they should overlap one is
Nathaniel Richards who comes from the
future medals with the Multiverse and he
wouldn't really spend time focused on
altering life forms as his mission is to
conquer and not to create there's also a
lot of people who think that Loki season
2 might even be re-shot in order to
incorporate the high evolutionary as
Kang but I doubt that as well Marvel
have just announced its release date in
October and therefore I think it's
likely a wrap with no room to do things
like reshooting an entire character
instead I think the high evolutionary
might in fact evolve himself but on a
personal level we saw this perf
perfectly in the case of Adam Warlock
who was granted a second chance that was
very much that rather than being stuck
as a Solace assassin he started to see
things from Another angle and in the end
he joined up with the Guardians now I
don't think that the evolutionary will
do that either as he has done a lot of
messed up things guy like he destroyed
an entire planet instead I think he may
end up going on to help people rather
than hurting them and as we know he has
a wealth of scientific knowledge it is
possible that they could also time in
with the upcoming X-Men movies in the
comics he was fascinated by the work of
Nathaniel Essex aka Mr Sinister also
yeah why is Nathaniel such a popular
name for Super Villains got both him and
Kang with that name and we might get a
Martha scene or something anyway we have
had teasers towards Mr Sinister in the
fox franchise but he's never actually
appeared on screen at any point
therefore I think this would be the
perfect opportunity and the best way
that they could introduce him say that
the evolutionary changes his ways we
could have Essex come to him of the guys
of being an ally and he could then take
his research and build upon it for his
own nefarious means this would then
allow the infamous X-Men villain to be
introduced as a big bear that builds off
the back of what's come before failing
that I think the evolutionary could work
as a character that shows not everyone
deserves a second chance a man was
chewing up the scenery non-stop in the
movie and I would love to see this kind
of performance repeated in something
else he's too good of a villain to go to
waste and when I saw the conversation on
Twitter I was over the moon because I
think he's the kind of person you want
back marvelous starting to really get to
the point now where the films have a ton
of strong villains and to me he is
definitely one of them also a lot of you
been asking me on what I think about
Echo dropping all its episodes in one
day I'm not gonna make a full video on
that but I can imagine that's Marvel
basically shown they don't have the
faith that people will come back week to
week Loki is getting its episodes
released weekly so I don't think every
show is gonna go to the binge model and
maybe with Echo their Jersey is being
summing out will be better serviced with
a one day drop doesn't necessarily mean
that the show is bad but if it is then
it's gonna mitigate people complaining
about it for six weeks straight or
however long it is I think there's some
big changes going on at Marvel at the
moment and Jeff loveness has recently
been dropped as the writer of Kang
Dynasty Josh from denim nerd said
something about this the other day that
I think Rings true and that is that the
phase four mentality had marveled
thinking that they could just give
everyone a show and people will watch it
because the brand recognition was so
good that hasn't been the case and with
Echo I think they've just weighed up the
options and saw that the binge model is
gonna work best for that kind of series
there isn't really a rule book to
streaming shows so yeah they're probably
going to take a chance on doing that in
the hopes that it yields the best
rewards anyway I thought I'd just tack
that onto the end of the video because I
know some of you guys wanted to know my
thoughts but I don't want to make a 10
minute video where it sounds like I'm
complaining non-stop which I often do to
be fair anyway back to the main point
let us know your thoughts on The
evolutionary in the comments section
section below last month we also ran a
competition giving away a copy of the
quantumania steelbook and the three
winners of that are on screen right now
if you want to support the channel for
as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below and
as a thank you you'll get access to
early videos every week we also have our
merch store over at xeroedition.com
which sells lots of nerdy inspired
t-shirts hats and more you just launched
a peacemaker and Drax inspired t-shirt
so if you want to head over there and
help us out then the links in the
description now if you want something
else to watch we've got to break down a
fast Exxon screen right now which we
talk about all the drama behind the
scenes what happens in the movie and
what we took from the ending let us know
below if you ever if you watched that
let us know your thoughts on The
evolutionary yeah hope you see over
there right after this by the way thanks
for clicking the video I've been Paul
and I'll see you next time take care
peace